this is a test launch of an iranian
rocket
iran has said the rocket would be used
to carry satellites into space
but some western countries have said
that iran could potentially use rockets
like this
to carry a nuclear device we are looking
uh to
uh to prevent iran from acquiring a
nuclear weapon
as iran reached new milestones in
uranium enrichment and limited access to
inspectors in 2021
questions have intensified over what is
actually happening at some nuclear
facilities where it handles uranium and
plutonium
the key ingredients for a nuclear bomb
these gaps in monitoring
will start to raise questions about
iran's intentions
iran has repeatedly denied that it is
making a bomb and said sites like these
produce energy
medical equipment and scientific
research
nuclear experts say this hardware can
potentially be used to produce weapons
and note the country has been using its
nuclear capabilities as leverage with
the international community
almost all of the technologies have a
civilian nuclear energy component but
they also have a nuclear weapons
component so what do we actually know
about iran's nuclear infrastructure
and how it might be used to make nuclear
weapons
iran has been building its nuclear
program for half a century
in the 1960s and 1970s when iran was
ruled by the
shah there was an initial interest in
nuclear technology spurred on
by the united states and actually some
of iran's oldest nuclear facilities were
built in that period
jeffrey lewis teaches classes on arms
control and is a non-proliferation
advocate after the shah fell all of that
cooperation was cut off and
iran had a kind of fitful relationship
trying to revive that nuclear program on
and off through the 1980s and 1990s
until we entered the early 2000s when
iran made a very significant commitment
to a nuclear program
in the early 2000s satellite imagery
began to reveal sites like natanz where
iran says it enriches uranium for its
nuclear power plants
natanz is a complex where iran conducts
most of its uranium enrichment
activities kelsey devonport is an
analyst at a non-partisan organization
that promotes arms control this facility
is quite large
it's big enough to house about a hundred
thousand centrifuges
centrifuges are devices that spin
uranium oxide to extract the useful
isotopes
in other words you want to remove
the vast majority of uranium that is
useless
from a nuclear reaction perspective
and really just leave a
condensed quantity of the good stuff as
part of a 2015 nuclear agreement terran
had agreed to allow inspectors to
monitor its nuclear facilities
limit the quantity of its uranium to 300
kilograms
and limit enrichment to a key level of
no more than 3.67
but after the united states withdrew
from the deal and reimposed sanctions in
2018
iran began breaching that limit this
year iran announced it would limit
inspections to sites like natanz
where it's been enriching uranium to
four point five percent
at five percent you have reactor fuel at
twenty percent you have scary reactor
fuel and at 90 percent you have the
material for a bomb
and in february of this year tehran said
it could dramatically increase its
levels of enrichment
it sounds like you haven't gone very far
of the way to 90
for a bomb but to go from zero to five
percent is
basically half the work that it will
take to go to 90
so if you have an enrichment capability
you really are going to have the
capacity to enrich to
the levels that would be needed for a
nuclear weapon and there's one site
where iran has already taken that
enrichment a step further
fordo it was constructed in secret and
only discovered by intelligence agencies
in 2009
ford is much smaller much more
consistent with the
size of a nuclear weapons facility and
its
enrichment halls are placed under a
mountain where they would be extremely
difficult to attack
and so when ford was revealed i think
most of us looked at the
characteristics of that facility and
thought that really looks
more like something that you would build
if you wanted a weapon than it does
if you were planning to make fuel for a
power plant iran halted production at
fodo under the 2015 nuclear deal
but in 2021 it said it resumed uranium
enrichment to 20
it says it's enriching to this level for
one of its research reactors in tehran
and that the facility is underground due
to a risk of u.s or israeli attack
all of these factors suggest that the
fordeau facility was likely being
designed
to produce fissile material for a
weapons program
if iran made the decision to pursue the
bomb another key step in manufacturing a
weapon is the ability to convert
enriched uranium into a metal and
esvahan
iran has a uranium metal facility and
this is quite concerning because uranium
metal
is another of these dual use areas you
know iran
claims that it's pursuing this
technology to produce uranium
metal fuel for its research reactor so
far inspectors seiran has only
constructed 3.6 grams of uranium metal
far less than the tens of kilos needed
for a bomb and at a purity below
weapons grade but still in breach of the
2015 nuclear agreement which prohibited
the production of the metal altogether
i would say the facility as a whole is
fundamentally civilian
the act of making uranium metal is
one of those 50 50 i would prefer you
not do it kind of things
iran has several other facilities
including iraq
where it could potentially produce
plutonium in early 2021 analysts
estimated it could have taken iran
between nine months and two years to
build a nuclear device
but some analysts say limiting
inspections may shorten that time
frame i don't think we're going to see
iran you know dash for a bomb
anytime soon but in this limbo and iran
will certainly seek
to preserve the nuclear technologies and
materials necessary
to pursue a bomb down the road if it
chooses to do so
iran has issued a number of statements
that have been interpreted as a threat
by western countries
iran
analysts say iran's rhetoric breaches of
the 2015 nuclear deal
and rocket launchers may actually be
aimed at one main goal
to be at the top of the us president's
agenda and negotiate the lifting of
sanctions
as international pressure and the
pandemic have thrown the country into a
deep economic crisis
it's been very transparent and upfront
about what measures it intends to
violate
and it has informed the international
atomic energy agency of those violations
in advance
so that they can be monitored that tells
us
that these measures are about leverage
and about creating pressure
and are not indicative of a dash towards
nuclear weapons